elles sont tout jeune retraité ses huit
poules vont passer quelques années chez
marie et pascal c est benoît viennent de
les adopter et leur ont évité l'abattoir
en bretagne le but c'est évidemment
d'avoir des offrait au quotidien le fait
qu'elle soit bien aussi ça nous
intéressait on habite en vallée de
chevreuse donc côté écologique on un
poulailler de luxe dans leur terrain
pour aller gambader de leur côté sans
abîmer ou jardin à côté
une initiative de poule pour tous depuis
trois ans l'entreprise nantaise propose
aux éleveurs de leur confier leur poule
à 18 mois les gallinacés pour moins
souvent les professionnels renouvellent
leur élevage
l'éleveur prend contact avec nous nous
on récupère la date de réforme donc
d'abattage que qui a été prévu pour cet
élevage et on fait des actions en amont
pour sensibiliser la population qui est
autour dans un premier temps et ensuite
s'il reste des poules on va aller un
petit peu plus loin les gallinacés et
est issu d'un élevage de plein air en
bretagne lors de cette opération
organisée à gaz rend 450 poule ont
trouvé une nouvelle famille